in our pockets today sits more knowledge
than any one individual could have ever
hoped to have in their lifetimes 15
years ago we're already aware that
there's a knowledge revolution on we see
it with children and how they do their
homework at school we see it in how we
think about issues but in many cases it
hasn't yet translated into the work
environment because it's still
relatively costly to accumulate because
they're in grain patterns of behavior
because it's a complex world and so
still today many many of our workers our
employees are on the knowledge side
their entry levels in accounting or in
legal or in in marketing and most of
their job is not to come to the big
decisions about where to drive the
business it's to be an assembler and
synthesizer of facts mostly to be able
to leverage knowledge and yet the rate
of change in information technology and
the speed that it's happening really
makes me question how long till we start
to see some of those activities being
replaced we already see computers being
used to process massive amounts of data
that no one person could ever do we see
many things in in all of these
communities being captured in
storehouses of knowledge but but that's
growing exponentially in terms of the
processing powers that exist our ability
to to both accumulate and synthesize
knowledge increasingly what the next
thing that will be the hardest to
replace is not the ability to have the
knowledge or to figure out which pieces
are important and package it effectively
it's the ability to solve problems to
look across the boundaries to work
collaboratively to drive change to bring
real insight into situations that
doesn't just arrived from staring at the
facts in doing an analysis that means we
need to educate our children differently
we need to provide different
apprenticeship models to the people that
we bring in where we give them broader
exposure more ability to think laterally
more ability to analogize and to
recognize that over time basic knowledge
stuff will be less important the ability
to generate that insight will be more
portant than ever